news on Lauri Lachlan in the college
bribery scandal some are speculating
that all the strain from her legal
proceedings could be tearing apart her
marriage Us Weekly claims Lauri and
Massimo have been fighting behind the
scenes and their daughter is afraid
their twenty-one year marriage is
heading for divorce according to our ET
source that claim is quote absolutely
untrue
the couple pleaded not guilty for their
role in the college bribery scandal last
April if found guilty they face up to 40
years in federal prison our source says
they quote have been standing by each
other's side since the beginning of all
this and will do so until it's
successfully resolved next Friday
September 13th Felicity Huffman will be
sentenced after pleading guilty for
paying fifteen thousand dollars for an
SAT scam prosecutors have recommended
four months behind bars which is much
lower than the maximum 20 years the
charges could carry while Lori and
Felicity's freedom hangs in the balance
that's not stopping lifetime from doing
what they do best ripping a story from
the headlines and pumping up the drama
only et has the exclusive first look of
the TV movie the College Admission
scandal which premieres October 12th I
will teach you
to make an impression the movie is
chosen not to use Laurie and Felicity's
names or likeness but there are obvious
similarities like Felicity Penelope Ann
Miller character pays big bucks for her
child to cheat on the SATs and like
Laurie Mia Kirchner plays a rich mom
accused of paying half a million dollars
to get her daughter on to eight
prestigious universities athletic team
he was exclusively on the set with the
cast earlier this summer my character is
so corrupt greedy narcissistic
self-centered and the dialogue is
hilarious so I'm glad that they're able
to capture humor
[Music]